how's everyone doing today
great very good i'm doing really good
um so i love i totally want to talk
about snakehead but i love asking a
curveball right at the beginning so for
each of you guys um what tv series with
for the actors what tv series would you
love to guest star on and evan what tv
series would you love to guest write and
direct
current tv show that's it it's on or any
in history
anything you want
okay
well i would i would love to i would
have loved to guest star in different
strokes
next to gary coleman that's that would
have been a dream or be in a movie with
him like you ever see his movies when
he's like a orphan that lives at like uh
like like the bus station and stuff like
i'd you ever see that like
i can't remember i don't remember the
title but i know it's like early 80s i
just don't remember
yeah i just don't remember the title
there was a slew of gary coleman films
that really touched your heart he was
always pl he was like the it was our era
of shirley temple movies basically
at least my era right
so anyway
yeah he was he's the only actor i've
ever been starstruck before he passed
away i met him at a restaurant and i was
stuttering when i went up to him because
i grew up with watching eric coleman man
i think i was like my hero you know
anyway
that's it
all right
to be on i love lucy
oh yeah nice yeah i love lucy yeah i
think that was
that was my favorite growing up was uh i
love lucy and it's just her comic sense
and style and timing it's you could
learn so much just volumes that i could
learn from her um if you think about it
jade there was never i don't think there
was ever an asian actress or actor on i
love lucia because i've watched i grew
up watching that show too or all of them
there was one i think there was one but
i think it was a waiter in a restaurant
or something like that but i but that
was it
i think you know when i was starting out
in the industry i think there were only
eight of us
in the whole united states
and there were no stories and so
everybody was scrambling for the same
role uh and there was never anything on
on network for us
it would have been awesome to see an
asian cuban
yeah
you know they have the asian cuban food
yeah
right
yeah so for me i guess it would be
something like games of thrones because
i like period pieces and and fantasy and
all that
um
i think it'd be fun to play one of those
characters so one of the really mean
ones maybe
again another series with
no asians
really yeah i know right
well no one here is uh asian she's asian
i mean we got jason mama too so he's
kind of asian yeah
kind of exciting yeah
um
yeah honestly i mean i think
i honestly wouldn't i don't want i'd
love to direct a law and order svu
because
my parents i watched all of them and my
parents loved that and i would love to
get something i could just talk about
with my mom at that level so
i appreciate you answering and this is
one of the reasons i like asking a
question like that because it sort of
gets to know you guys without um you
know what i mean it lets you know a
little bit about what you like anyway so
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you guys today um uh evan i know
you've been trying to get this movie
made for a long time can you sort of
talk about did you ever think
[ __ ] this is never gonna happen
yeah i mean i i knew it was gonna happen
i just didn't know when it was gonna
happen i think you know i think you
start off making this film in 2008 and
it was really just a trying moment like
how why is this so hard to get done and
uh you know at the same time like you
get these little moments of success
these little moments of bumps and
excitement which you know the hollywood
sort of industry gives you and uh
and and you could you continue and i
think you just have these little moments
a little win here little one there a
little meeting there another investor
here and uh you you you get it keeps you
going and really um
at the end i knew i had to get this done
because otherwise my wife was going to
kill me so you know that's really uh
a huge driving force in my life
i hate asking the generic question but
for people that haven't seen the movie
yet even maybe they haven't seen the
trailer yet um how have you been
describing the film i'm not sure who
wants to evan i don't know if you want
to give you a quick one quick one
i mean so for me
it's scarface uh but instead of a cuban
man it's a chinese woman and instead of
smoking cocaine into the country she's
smuggling people um and so you know this
movie is made in this in in in that in
that realm i mean i grew up in america
and i grew up in the 80s i love scarface
godfather goodfellas and you know this
is kind of like you know an iteration of
that sort of world of the american
gangster uh for the cast um i'm curious
what was it about the script and story
that said uh i i have to do this i want
to do this
well there's not many female strong
female characters in hollywood to start
with but for asian american or asian
issue male even you know there's not
many characters like this so for me
as a female asian actress i was like oh
my god this is such a meaty character it
has so much you can work with uh
i was blown away when i read the script
that's basically what it was
yeah and it's you know how many uh older
asian american women
lead roles are there
none um you know and very few
we have it in different ethnicities
coming before but
how could any actor turn down
dima you know i i i just can't even
imagine any actor turning that down
um i was able to you know
live with this story and the script
since you know evan came up with it
years ago so you know the the
opportunity to be able to work with the
old friend on his first feature was
definitely you know
highlighted and you know attractive for
me and and that's where you know that
that relationship gave us the ability to
create a character from ground up and
on paper
character like rambo could be so
one-dimensional but you know gave us the
opportunity to really
develop something with the real estate
we had so
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of any project so
for you guys what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of snakehead
i mean it was made of on no money
basically this movie and
what surprised me the most was the
community our asian community just
showed up
basically working for free just for food
you know and and wanted to make this
movie happen everyone was just so
passionate about it you know in the crew
and outside of it everyone was just so
excited and that actually surprised me
so much it's so much so many people
showed up
for the movie like
i was amazed
yeah obviously the community was totally
there for us um i mean actually from a
real interesting example we had this
huge
boat scene as a climax
point in this film that you know
we got this free boat and we got 100
extras in florida and you know we needed
them to be asian there's not that many
chinese people in florida so we had to
get from you know senior citizens to
young kids to play the extras and um you
know it was this massive boat scene with
this big climax and guns and action
and i mean we had to take out the movie
it didn't work for the story and you
know that was you know one of the you
know obvious you hear about killing your
darlings and killing your biggest scene
and and we literally had to do the
hardest scene you had to take out of
this film and um
you know i i think it it it it's
it was a learning lesson it was a big
lesson for me and also you know this
movie is so ambitious and you know you
get to realize like what story are you
trying to tell and what's important and
that's one of the bigger lessons i have
to learn um yeah it's the the like what
suya said and and and uh evan about the
community because
it comes from the leader um and
what evan did was he created a world it
wasn't just a community it was a world
because this was shot internationally it
was shot domestically in different
locations
and everywhere he went he was able to
draw the passion for the milk film and
the story
and that was a surprise because making
an indie film is so hard anyway but to
be able to go to these foreign locations
and have everyone come to four is
is really surprising because i i've made
a few indie films and
it's not that easy to do and he created
a miracle
one of the things that i thought was
very well done about the film one of the
many things is that you're portraying a
story on screen that often isn't
depicted and it's another side of new
york city that you know there's not a
lot of limelight on it um can you sort
of talk about what why this story was
important to you to
you know get told and put on the screen
yeah i mean new york chinatown is is is
a wonderful um fantastic sort of place
right and and
um i really wanted to make sure that new
york chinatown was a character in this
film right and i think it it represents
something that i i get to see and so you
always have this world that these
characters living in and this is sort of
like an an underwater sort of world of
of of just um
fantastic sort of experiences you know
and and and beauty in the in the
underworld and so
for me um
new york chinatown and and telling that
story was something i never got to see
told from our perspective and that was
really what was important for us to do
uh for the actors you guys all get to
essentially be badasses in your own way
uh how much fun is it playing a role
like that where you are the badass
oh it's so much fun i mean again this is
such a meaty role right no only sisters
see a very strong character but
there's also a lot of pain underneath
and and she's very vulnerable and she
cannot show that because she has to be
smart in what she does every move she
does you know it's all for sacrifice of
her daughter or her family she's just
trying to protect that and try to get to
her
so
again i was in candyland to be able to
play a role like that
yeah i think with badass roles there it
comes with a certain
degree of power and with power
what people don't see is a
responsibility for that power how do you
accept that responsibility how do you
manifest it um and i think that
dimension that uh
in the story
is able to flesh out characters that you
wouldn't normally see
oh yeah
playing the bet playing a baddie is
always fun you know and
getting to do the research is is it's
even more fun because you get to go
and meet former or current people that
you know live in this world so we had
the luxury we had a lot of great
consultants in the community that came
out and shared their stories so
you know to be a sponge and to be able
to listen to the history and you know
some of it is
a little inflated and you know the
stories can be a little you know like
overly dramatic at times but it's it's
fun to be a fly on the wall and listen
to that history and then being able to
you know hopefully bring that to life in
a in a human like relatable way um it's
it's it's super cool you know it's and
when there's a little you know hot sauce
on it and when you know there's a little
touch of of a badness or evil to it it
makes it that much more interesting
that's also very human i mean we all
have those sides we just don't
absolutely it's like a family you know
behind the closed doors of a house you
know you see the dynamic of the actual
family members and and that you so
rarely see in films you only see the
surface and that with chinatown too you
only see as a tourist you see chinatown
in manhattan you know going there to eat
chinese food
but you don't see the underbelly of it
you guys i would imagine getting ready
to make this movie or i'm guessing that
you probably did a little bit of
research in terms of the story you're
depicting and you know
was there anything for each of you that
you guys learned that you were really
surprised by
you know i was surprised about it well
yeah all right
yeah there's just a natural organic
i guess hierarchy to
you know this world and
um
you know the character that daima was
like represented the people that we met
actually knew her at one point and you
know it wasn't this
like like you know story of this crazy
maniacal lady you know she was almost
like like the city mayor you know there
was she was well respected she was
you know there was this
this level of esteem and
um
i guess you know contribution from her
and you know
most of the time when you hear about
like you know
like criminals within you know a
community like chinatown it's so
one-dimensional you know they're just
evil and they just did it for money and
greed but then you realized that most of
this stuff was necessity you know and
she was actually
in the community and a lot of people
under in this like underbelly of crime
in chinatown and and many ethnic
communities you know it's it's a matter
of necessity and there is such a human
side and and a level of like respect
with these individuals which they'll
call me by surprise because i went in
there with his own prejudice and going
oh these are criminals and they do bad
things and all they care about is money
but then
it's not you know they're they're
they're mothers and their sisters and
their daughters and you know there is
this really human side to them that you
know i think that's what i think this
whole story and this exploration of
these characters are and that's where it
goes back to the responsibility of power
you know dimond takes on this position
because nobody no one else will do it
and you know i think you know that it's
it's
she has this obligation and the
community that she created that brought
she brought over to your country
um you know they're obligated back to
her so that's is it respect is it
obligation
is it just um it's not just money that
people are owing you know they're owing
their lives they would not have this
life in america had she not brought them
over
well uh they've given me the signal
about uh time i'm just gonna say that
i've spoken to a number of people about
uh independent movies and how
challenging they are to make and to get
off the ground and i really say uh
congratulations on finally getting this
film made evan and you guys all did such
a great job uh i look forward to
promoting it on collider as you guys
know we did the trailer um so um thank
you thank you for giving me your time
and i wish you nothing but the best